empathy and compassion is such a  difficult skill to own i hear this a lot  where people say but gary that's hard or  people say easier said than done that's  right that's exactly right the reason  the [ __ ] that i talk about is so [ __ ]  powerful and so goddamn important is  because it's so hard for 90 of the world  the reason it's so awesome is because  it's hard like the good stuff is hard  all the great [ __ ] is hard that's it you  know what else is hard eating healthy  and working out like it's hard like  being a parent it's [ __ ] hard like  shit's hard and empathy and compassion  and patience is [ __ ] hard i know it's  hard and it's still the [ __ ] medicine  it's the medicine we all need